hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
mir mal wieder eine mystery box bestellt
danke für den tollen applaus falls sie
nicht genau wissen was eine ebay mystery
box ist das ist natürlich überhaupt kein
problem das kann ich euch natürlich
konzern stellen verschiedene nutzer
einfach boxen rhein wo sie irgendeinen
scheiß zusammen gepackt haben und diese
hier habe ich mir bestellt
ja cool oder
der inhalt dieser box soll einen
gesamtwert von 50 euro haben
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das wirklich
stimmt weil da können natürlich auch
leute irgendeinen scheiß reinpacken und
das einfach für 50 euro verkaufen aber
ich würde sagen wir öffnen das ganze
paket jetzt mal und ich sehe schon das
erste was hier drin ist ein rauchglas
eine 2000 jahre später gewinnt also
mysteriöser mystery box zusammenstellung
von ebay dankeschön für diese die bitte
auf jeden fall einen sehr schönen ort
haben ich hoffe ich musste mich also
häufig gießen
wir gehen jetzt blind in die kiste rein
und ich greife einfach mal dieses
produkts hier raus das ist ein weißes
verpacktes etwas artikelnummer 0 12 für
ihre hau mich tod hat liegt noch nicht
was darin ist er mich packt das ganze
einfach mal aus ich glaube es ist eine
tasse und zwar das ist eine tasse mit so
ein bisschen papier aber nur zum stopfen
hier steht alter das ist mir so egal
mein lebensmotto auf einer tasse also
dankeschön auch für diese tasse ich
trinke nicht so gern kaffee deswegen
macht uns nicht allzuviel sind habe ich
trinke ich darf auf jeden fall benutzen
als nächstes haben wir hier das das ist
glaube ich ein handschuh den man
irgendwie anders sehen kann
decker warum ist denn beim immer sonne
scheint im mystery boxes denn man müsste
wie blogs youtube eingeht dann kommt das
und videos die auf 10.000 euro mystery
box aber nachholt extrem sonnig krieg
ich richtig zum komischen handschuh so
eine kaffeetasse und ihm so eine halbe
aber wir machen mal direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten produkt und zwar ist es
dass hier das gibt mir aus
einem armband das hilft mir auf jeden
fall noch definitiv ins handgelenk
passen also ich probier's mal nicht kann
es höchstens so tragen dankeschön auch
dafür nächstes produkt was ich in dieser
50 euro bis zur box befindet freunde ist
kassieren jetzt ist meine box kaputt
gegangen
ich weiß nicht genau was das hier ist
mir steht fashion radiergummi sexy po
mein gott das sind session radiergummis
also wir haben beispielsweise sowohl
schüchen einen hohen schuhen und noch
drin wir haben so eine fashion hand hat
schon ehering und noch ganz viel
weiterer scheiß er werde ich meiner
nicht vorhandenen kleinen baby schwester
schenken aber wir machen direkt weiter
mit dem nächsten wurde über sicheren
befindet und zwar ein buch das tholi der
hütte bietet musik der berge nicht mal
wissen was vorlesen
der tierarzt kam kilian und er waren die
nächsten stunden damit beschäftigt der
coup beim kalben beizustehen neugierig
standen die kinder dabei kam dachte
nicht mehr an barbara die bunte warf ein
kräftiges bohlen kalb es war tiefbraunen
wie seine farbe es geht gerade darum
dass eine kuh ein kind bekommt also ich
pack das mal beiseite wir machen wir
gerade mit dem nächsten gegenstand der
sich in dieser box befindet nämlich
gerade jetzt noch ein bisschen tiefer
hinein und zwar haben wird
arbeitshandschuhe der chip hat somit
seinen handschuhen oder arbeiten schon
kann man aber auf jeden fall mal
gebrauchen deswegen bin ich eigentlich
sehr dankbar für als nächstes haben wir
ein zumba fitness gürtel scheiße da
braucht man noch eine fernbedienung für
also ich weiß nicht was das ganze
darstellen soll irgendwie muss man hier
in schlappe verschiedene termine und das
kann ich meiner mutter schenken der
nächste gegenstand der hier eingepackt
wurde minister einig ist auch ein
bisschen größer und zwar ein ganzkörper
badeanzug
ich weiß ihr wollt sicherlich dass ich
denn jetzt anziehe und damit das video
hier weitermache aber hunde keinen
scheiß ich weiß ja cool also das hier
ist dieser maler anzug der ist megageil
hatte eine kapuze damit die haare nicht
als dankeschön auch für diesen badeanzug
kann nicht bestimmen dann irgendwann
gebrauchen wenn ich irgendwann in zehn
jahren mal ein kind habe und ein hausbau
unterstreichen muss oder
jaroslaw machen will also hell freunde
hast like da wenn wir in der luke rusal
doch nun machen wir direkt weiterhin mit
dem nächsten gegenstand in der mystery
box uns will der mich papa paper
decoration da werde ich doch verarschen
als nächstes haben wir hier einfach
einen zettel von sandalen und darin
eingewickelt eine ikea blumenvase wo
vielleicht eine halbe blume reinpasst
dafür stehen auf jeden fall auch dafür
werde ich definitiv nie in meinem leben
gebrauchen nehme jetzt als nächstes
etwas was wir sehr großes und zwar eines
das ist das sind spielkarten das gibt es
ja mal mega geil alter ich weiß nicht
warum oder ist auch mein gott welchen
kartentricks sehen sie mal eine karte
ja ich lege würden pixie richtig bin
beginnt mit mit tischen mag ja auch in
deutsch
das hier ist ohne spaß bisher das
allermeiste was in dieser box drin war
also einfach so riesige spielkarten das
ist mégane ist da kann endlich keine
mehr unters sofa fallen
na ja die können ja doch hinter das sofa
fallen also die sind ja immer noch
relativ dünn weil es ja auch egal
freunde da freue ich mich auf jeden
fernseher darüber habe ich letztens
schon mal eine
in einem laden gesehen in köln fand ich
auf jeden fall ganz klar überlegen das
kein scheiß ist ein kugelschreiber aber
es sieht so aus wie kennt ihr diese
kugelschreiber diese elektrisch sind ich
will's nicht hessen ich fasse den nicht
an er hat auf jeden fall wieder hier
vorne drin also danke für diesen
kugelschreiber als nächstes fasst sich
jemand wieder ein name wie eine zeitung
schaue ich mal was hier einfach mal die
gleiche blumenvase sind türkis sagte
schön dafür auf jeden fall werde ich
auch nicht so toll gebrauchen können
weil ich nicht so viele blumen hier drin
habe dann das hin dass bauer ein
ich weiß nicht was es für ein vogel ist
aber es ist ein vogel der klasse oder
also dankeschön auch für diesen
wundervollen vogel nächster gegenstand
der sicheren befindet die relativ leer
also ja ich weiß nicht warum mir auch
bei diesen bei dieser euro challenge
brille mitgebracht hat aber die alles
die folgen aus steht mir diese brille
ich weiß es nicht ich werde sie auf
jeden fall nicht tragen in der
öffentlichkeit next brave wendel sagte
erwachsen die gesetzlichen krankenkassen
haben zweistellige milliardenbeträge auf
der hohen kante und das jahr 2017 mit
einem dicken überschuss beendet geil die
boxnacht sich wirklich langsam schon im
ende zu als nächstes haben wir hier das
hat man schon da fühlen können nämlich
irgendwelche 1,5 wollen das in kohle
batterien in den letzen ist für blogs
hat sich ja auch eine menge batterien
drin ich weiß nicht warum ihr alle eure
batterien
wegschickt als nächstes produkt haben
wir hier ein
das ist glaub ich von dem router oder
also irgend so ein router stücke dann
haben wir hier vorne einfach gut
swatch oder dich ich keine ahnung von
uhren also diese uhr war hier auch noch
drin in dem in dem 50 euro package hier
ich weiß nicht wie ich die auf mache so
mache ich mir auch keine kann ich
nochmal um fakten ich glaube die passt
sogar um ein handgelenk so die passen
die passt sogar perfekte mein handgelenk
also hey jude als nächstes produkt haben
wir hier denkt mit hygiene tücher die
sind sogar echt eigentlich ganz nice die
dann auf jeden fall behalten dann haben
wir hier als nächstes produkt noch eine
kleine holzschatulle ich glaube ich hab
mir direkten später eine hand gehauen
wenn mit ihnen aufmachen sehen wir sogar
dass sich dort etwas drin befindet
nämlich den online kann ich mir nicht
wirklich in die haare klemm
wie findet ihr mein outfit gerade ich
finde dafür auf jeden fall schon mal
leichter lassen freunde zählen bei aller
kittel wird diesen dingen gehört mit
meiner neuen swatch uhren die sagt halbe
da vorne aber wir schauen mal was ich
dir sonst was drin befindet
hier haben wir bloß weg sie sind auf
jeden fall auch ganz neues wenn irgend
einmal geburtstag hat oder so wenig die
definitiv nicht verwenden ich schaue mir
jetzt einfach rein weil ich nicht mehr
erfüllen konnte das einzige was ihr noch
drin ist ein happy new year anstecker
die man sich hier dran machen kann wird
aber nicht nur ein tolles outfit gerade
ruinieren und einen glasboden also auch
dankeschön dafür
wir können an die box reinschauen die
befindet sich nichts mehr wir haben die
box komplett leer gemacht ja und was
können jetzt abschließend sagen freunde
das hier ist der komplette inhalt der
sich in der box befindet hat also
insbesondere wir hatten die sind blumen
zeile werden batterien eine taste an
schwung
ich weiß nicht was das für komische
handschuhe sind auf jeden fall eine
bessere ausbeute würde ich sogar
tatsächlich sagen als bei meinem ersten
mystery box video und jetzt die frage an
euch freunde wollt ihr dass ich mal eine
100 euro
ebay mystery box mache also nicht mache
aber mir bestelle dann lasst dann
leichter freunde und wie ich bereits zu
beginn eingeblendet habe schaffen wir
80.000 likes wenn ihr 80.000 geschafft
weiß ich okay und ihre freiheit diese
band mystery post openings keine ahnung
was unboxing und dann werde ich mir auf
jeden fall mal 100 euro box bestellen
dann schauen wir mal was ich dort und so
befindet und so als würde ich an der
stelle jetzt einfach auch nur noch sagen